pamela with romantic comedies is falling
in love really supposed to be funny
well falling in love seldom is funny now
it's hopefully fun but I think what
romantic comedies and the funny look at
the situations can do for us is it can
make it easier for us to take a look at
what happens and how frightened we
sometimes get if the changes that are
happening when we start falling in love
and the resistance that comes from
within and often from without you know
from friends and family who know what
are you doing with that person and maybe
society's strictures against who you're
falling in love with so to take a
comedic look at some of those situations
can be helpful because then you can go
oh okay other people have faced this
kind of situation here are some
solutions maybe we can work that out too
I know in looking at your book romantic
comedies you used one of the case
studies of I think my Big Fat Greek
Wedding and sounds like we're talking a
lot of the similar things where the out
the family was so strong that they only
wanted you know they were very
possessive and also too they had her
sort of as this one type of person and
kind of gave her the impression she
couldn't have another type that that was
the beauty of the film that two
opposites came together yes it's a very
good example of that and I think it's
also a a good example when we say
falling in love note the word falling
okay you're going from one position as
the daughter who always does it this way
as the member of the family who this is
the way we do it you're falling into a
different realm and I've often wondered
though why we don't like slide into love
okay it's not a horizontal movement or
why we don't rise into love but of
course if it's well done you do rise up
you do have that that uplifting of your
spirit but falling in love you're
falling off that level where you've been
you're going to a different realm it's a
different world and so I think the
beauty of room
anta comedies is that it can make it a
little bit more palatable to take a look
at the things that happen to us now why
do people love romantic comedies and I
realize not everybody does but we all
have a soft spot for at least one that's
that's true we all we all do have a soft
spot for at least one I will admit when
the publishers came and we were talking
about a new book Kenley said oh you know
there's this study that's been done and
we think that maybe that would make a
good book well what was it said well
couples who watch romantic comedies
together versus the other group of
couples who went to couples therapy an
amazing thing happened the stay together
rate was higher for those who watched
comedies together and talked about them
then it was for those who went to
couples therapy now I still think
couples therapy is a good idea but wait
until you get to that point romantic
comedies now you say well does everybody
like romantic comedies frankly I didn't
that much when Ken and I were talking
about this and he said well we think
he'd be a good person to write this book
I said uh you know I do mythology and
military stuff right an adventure you
guys no no no you you'll do a good job
with it well thanks to he and Michael we
see of Michael we see productions it was
a group effort on constructing how the
chapters would be laid out and how we'd
approach each film so me a person who
was not that much of a rom-com fan I
actually became one through the process
of writing this book
you